well in the last 20 years there have
been great changes for people with
intellectual disabilities many countries
have passed laws that open schools to
children with intellectual disabilities
it's hard to believe but just a few
generations ago a few decades ago many
children with disabilities were never
allowed to go to school schools were
told what would tell parents no there is
no place in this school for your child
so schools have opened up in some places
employers have begun to see a person
with an intellectual disability as
someone who can contribute someone who
will be a loyal worker someone who will
be a reliable worker someone who will
help create a positive environment at
work so employers have begun the long
process of opening their doors of
opportunity to people with intellectual
disabilities and health care
institutions have begun to study the
various forms of intellectual disability
and begun to respond with new kinds of
treatments new kinds of interventions
new kinds of therapies that not only
help prevent those forms of intellectual
disability that are preventable but also
it may be more importantly add to the
quality of life of those who have an
intellectual disability and want to
contribute so changes have been positive
in most countries do we still have work
to do alas yes all the positive changes
in employment and health care community
living education are still unfortunately
isolated examples most children with
intellectual disabilities never go to
school more than ninety percent never
have a job almost all of them never have
real friends very few still ever get to
play on a sports team ever get to join a
community organization ever get to stand
up in front of a crowd and say look what
I've done look how well I've done give
me a chance at a metal give me a chance
at a cup give me a chance at success
that experience is still tragically the
rarest of experiences in the lives of
people with intellectual disabilities
and their families our job is to change
that
well the biggest barrier facing people
with intellectual disabilities in almost
every country in the world is fear and
misunderstanding negative attitudes
people still believe that a child with
an intellectual disability is somehow
lesser and so they say to parents so I'm
sorry you have such a child they say to
the child either in words or
non-verbally I'm so sorry that you're
having to live such a tragic life it
couldn't be in many respects a further
thing from the truth but that bias
translates into a lack of health care
because people think why bother giving
health care to these children it
translates into a lack of special
educators because people think why
bother with special education we have to
train and educate other kids it
translates into a lack of employment
opportunities because people think why
bother hiring this person they'll never
contribute anything the biggest barrier
is the negative attitude the the result
of negative attitudes our whole system's
whole social structures that too
frequently say to a child with
intellectual disability you are not
welcome our job is to reverse those
negative attitudes and create
communities that say you are welcome
show me what you can do you can
contribute to the life of this community
to the life of this country
well I think the CRC is sufficient as
far as it goes it's a piece of paper
it's a document it's a government
document the real question is not is the
wording right the real question is is
the implementation right where are the
people where are the armies of citizens
who will take the challenge of the CRC
and make it come to life the real
urgency of now is not to have signatures
on the bottom of the page but to have
people in communities who are doing the
work of overturning the attitudes and
ensuring that the rights of the child
with an intellectual disability are
protected where are the teachers who
will understand that the CRC is an
invitation to them to open their
classrooms where are the principles and
the educators who will see in the CRC a
challenge to them to make sure their
school has special educators and other
resources where are the mayor's and the
Chiefs and the local officials who will
say the CRC is a challenge to my
community to become an an icon of
acceptance to become the place where
people want to visit to see what it
means to be inclusive this army where
the parents the young people the
religious leaders the civic leaders who
themselves through every little fiber of
this of the community can begin to weave
in that there's a place for the person
with special needs in my church in my
synagogue in my temple in my school in
my institution in my place of work in my
home on my playground in my Park when
that happens the CRC will no longer be
on paper it will be it will have come to
life that will be the measure of its
success in the moment of celebration
you